[Música]
ya lo decíamos en directo a vamos a eeuu
porque las autoridades fronterizas
informaron que aumentaron
considerablemente las detenciones de
migrantes provenientes de venezuela cuba
y nicaragua que cruzan irregularmente la
frontera sur esto al tiempo que
disminuyó la cifra de mexicanos y de
otros países de donde tradicionalmente
parten los migrantes conectamos con
cristóbal vázquez corresponsal de france
24 en la capital estadounidense
cristóbal a qué se debe este aumento de
los arrestos en agosto según los
oficiales como se compara con las cifras
de la administración anterior
el aumento de arrestos en agosto se debe
en gran parte al aumento general de
migrantes que están llegando no solo de
centroamérica sino también de cuba y
venezuela- según la agencia de aduanas y
project y protección de fronteras de
eeuu el mes pasado se detuvieron a más
de 55.000 personas que trataron de
entrar a eeuu de forma ilegal al
respecto crist magnus comisionado de
esta agencia dijo en un comunicado que
los regímenes comunistas fallidos en
venezuela nicaragua y cuba están
impulsando precisamente esta nueva ola
de migración en todo el hemisferio
occidental
incluyendo el reciente aumento de
detenciones en la frontera suroeste de
eeuu otro de los factores que ha
influido en el aumento de detenciones es
que el presidente bailén pues ha
mantenido en pie el título 42 una medida
sanitaria de prevención contra el coi
que permite a la patrulla fronteriza
detener y expulsar inmediatamente a
inmigrantes indocumentados hay que
mencionar que durante los cuatro años de
trump el promedio de detenciones era
cercano al medio millón de personas al
año según datos de la patrulla
fronteriza cifras muy a los dos primeros
años de la administración de bailén y
como queda atrás este informe el tema
migratorio de cara a las elecciones de
medio término
el tema migratorio con el del aborto es
el tema más recurrente de las campañas
de los candidatos republicanos al
congreso del discurso del gran reemplazo
de la raza blanca por cuenta de
inmigrantes genera mucho miedo y
participación en los votantes sobre todo
en aquellos de áreas rurales de eeuu los
candidatos republicanos están apelando a
este miedo para lograr más votos y
recuperar la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes y en el senado en las
elecciones de noviembre sin embargo las
cifras de detenciones de emigrantes y de
gastos en seguridad la frontera
contradicen los argumentos de los
republicanos sobre la falta de acción de
los demócratas frente a la crisis de
inmigración ilegal sin embargo el
discurso que los republicanos son más
fuertes que los demócratas en cuanto a
migración ha calado en la opinión
pública acciones como la de los
gobernadores de la florida de texas hace
unos días pagando viajes en buses y en
aviones con migrantes a ciudades como
nueva york chicago y washington
refuerzan el mensaje de que los
demócratas no están haciendo lo
suficiente y que hacen los envíos
para que los progresistas del norte
experimenten lo que viven los estados
fronterizos